you're up in the middle of the night and
again you're in trouble in love you had
another discussion over dinner you tried
to get them to see that sometimes
because of X you do y and they respond
with zed and it's unpleasant and they
counted at first politely and then with
mounting irritation that even though a
you think B and that's why C is
maddening to them both of you tried
pretty valiantly to get get your points
across with calm and kindness both of
you managed to be more or less polite
more or less restrained more or less
grown up and by the end of two hours of
conversation you parted in an almost
affectionate way and went to sleep in
different rooms but it's not enough and
you know it that's why you're up at 3:00
a.m. hearing the rainfall you're pursued
by questions what do you keep doing
wrong in love do you even belong
together with this obviously very nice
person why is it so hard you briefly
wonder what it would be like to leave
you picture some new dates but the
picture soon curdles the horror of
starting all over again with someone new
you'd miss your partner you have a lot
of shared memories there used to be
until quite recently considerable hope
you don't know what to do if only there
was someone to speak to a wise kind
person who would know how to cut through
this then you realize that more than a
solution what you really want is someone
who could understand how hard it is that
there isn't one someone who would just
say I know I know sometimes we don't
need Solutions we need sympathy for our
impasses we need to know that we're not
idiots for having the challenges we have
that other sensible people have been
here too that it could almost be okay to
have this difficulty forever maybe it's
just one of life's given that's when a
bracing pessimistic philosophy is called
for the sort that says of course you're
miserable you're alive of course it's a
mess welcome to existence of course love
is a bit impossible you're a human being
this isn't the first choice naturally
you wanted to sort this out perfectly
the way you like to sort out other
things perfectly at work in domestic
life but this isn't a cupboard or an
accounting document the number of people
who have this area of Life properly
sorted out is minuscule perhaps below 1%
sent you have failed here that's for
sure but you're not exceptionally stupid
for that you're averagely mad averagely
emotionally perturbed and what you're
trying to do is something exceptionally
extraordinarily dementedly hard poor you
and poor all of us